[Music]
this bling junkie show with Hal Rudnick
hey everybody welcome to screen junkies
we're here with the always hilarious Rob
Corddry Rob I guess today I should
probably call you Rob Zombie your
portrayal of zombie is very impressive
that's right
I'd like to get your thoughts on other
motion picture television zombies
Walking Dead both Night of the Living
Dead kind of like the bull mix Shaun of
the Dead like what food becomes after a
bull is eating it and digested it those
guys go into work and they go you know
and I do extensive research I studied
some of the greats Daniel day-lewis I
read his book it's always Daniel
day-lewis day I think if you watch
Daniel day-lewis you'll know the number
one rule is don't break character and
and III think my co-stars really
respected it he committed to the role
and he made everyone else's life a
misery what was it like working with Rob
Corddry
I am literally in love with him failure
to launch him and SJP that chemistry is
palpable are you kidding me
he was definitely in that movie failure
to launch what about when you left set
yeah still yeah driving home I'd be dead
driving home I would be dead did that
ever lead to any kind of accidents yes
all the time
around your family would you stay that's
zombified yes of course it's so funny my
daughter would come up to me while we
were shooting they came up and and she'd
say daddy I miss you daddy I don't think
I'll ever be the same after this stuff
like that like just what kids will say
if you can fool a child into thinking
that you're dead and you hate her then
you're doing something right
that's Olivier right who's that he would
bring his arm brains to set em to eight
at lunch time is that DeNiro when
filming Raging Bull would eat a whole
chicken feathers and all that every day
I would eat a real human brain also with
feathers because feathers are delicious
you are not Daniel day-lewis playing
Abraham Lincoln you were the dude from
Hot Tub Time Machine how did you go
about getting human brains I know a guy
long story short you just have to ask
for him so it seems like you really
pushed method acting to its limits it
only seems that way because that's
exactly what is happening right now
for instance the dead don't urinate so I
did not urinate it's impossible how much
urine is in my bladder and I will not
ever let it go go ahead you hit me right
my bladder and you'll see I will not
nothing will happen hit me right yeah
make it count
actually I just did pee a little bit we
comment that different anger when the
same because before I felt like you I
heard that he used being a zombie as an
excuse to touch inappropriate late touch
yeah he would kind of put his hands on
you and then go in for like a slight
boob grab he just took it a little bit
too far sometimes did he touch you take
it off get everything on right now by
him ladies and gentlemen that is a
picture wrap on Rob Corddry this stuff
sticks with you sometimes but it did
help me land my next role can you tell
us what that is well let's just say this
you can call me mr. president you're an
artist your words not mine
but yes I'm an artist can I say it a lot
so they are my words I had a super fun
time and I got to say thanks to the
whole cast and crew of warm bodies
let's check the movie out so zombie
aficionados what's your favorite way to
kill a zombie is it a spike to the head
light saber them in half kill them with
kindness leave a comment below telling
us the best way to kill a zombie and
we'll send the best answer screen
junkies t-shirt I'm Hal Rudnick bye-bye